qui à partir de demain matin entreprend
de se construire un avenir nouveau
nous avons tous combattu espérer rêver
nous voulons tous que ce pays change
désormais n'être pas seulement citoyens
le dimanche quand on vote et sujet
l'amour trahi mais voir la démocratie
aller jusque sur les lieux du travail
désormais que nos conditions de vie de
savè de rémunération de travail de
revenus soit négocié vraiment désormais
au lieu de rester dans cette habitude
séculaire de tout attendre du commandant
ho dans cette france préfectoral is et
comme on dit trop souvent caporaliser
changer cela pour devenir tous citoyens
actifs à part entière et pourtant mes
amis ce soir je ne me sens pas le droit
de ne pas vous dire que ce sera
difficile
ceux d'en face ont perdu le pouvoir
politique
ils ont perdu la présidence de la
république et tout ce qu'elle représente
et françois mitterrand que vous avez
vues dans toute cette campagne puissant
combatif convaincu énergique en pleine
forme sera sûrement à la hauteur de sa
tâche
mais ils ne seront pas les seuls vous le
savez déjà
et votre vente comme votre joie sont
autant d'engagement la droite n'a pas
perdu encore le pouvoir économique pas
non plus encore le pouvoir d'influencé
d'information elle se battra